no va
[Música]
y desfiles como estos donde se llevan
los álamos son parte central de la
ceremonia del estás uva y el ashura los
dos días sagrados del chiísmo y uno de
los temores de las autoridades era que
tan grandes iban a hacer estas
procesiones durante estos días y a pesar
de que hay muchos en la calle nunca se
compara con años anteriores
estamos aquí por el amor del imán
hossein trajimos este al am hasta aquí
por todos los que tienen deseos y
ofrendas que hacer todo el que lo
sostiene sus deseos se hacen realidad
en la ciudad
en oración que se caracteriza por atraer
a millones de jóvenes
[Música]
la política
y muchos valores
[Música]
si asistimos a una ceremonia donde está
presente el espíritu de inma 26 al igual
que de otros y malos definitivamente no
vamos a infectar nos con el virus usted
puede ver que todas las personas
conservan los protocolos
[Música]
participo en estas ceremonias desde que
era una niña por eso no quiso faltar
este año
vine a mostrar mi dolor pero guardando
los protocolos
d
ustedes son las cercanías del bazar de
teherán uno de los lugares neurológicos
de la conmemoración de la sura en
teherán y lo que vemos a mis espaldas
esperanza gente reclamando comida del
bambú sino el masri que saluda las cosas
más características de esta
conmemoración y que este año solamente
se hizo en lugares muy específicos
porque estaba prohibido